it meant open the band so you teeth give
us our rights back in which you've
stolen it we even break these proxy war
it I think is the body of Roxy Devon in
follow man George
solid
our local media then cover it they're
scared of internet YouTube all these
mediums which you cannot control the
power lies with the artist the Creator
who uploads the acts and autocomplete
for Vendetta Masterton Optimus hackers
was doing bad woman with where power
spot with some rappers but now I have to
hide my ass what's important for us as a
society to get up and fight for our
rights because if we don't then one by
one all these rights will be born
noxious in Crete the banning future this
is an easy way just easy politicians
with their common reason to pays and
scummy supervillains with control over
what you play and who's to say they can
when they bring the money to pay they go
enforce the censorship the bigger
threats and be in charge of important
decisions blatant hypocrisy was bullshit
morbid conviction